[Music]  I'm ready  Amber  [Music]  you're out there and you're listening  but also worried about you  nothing wrong  we're gonna find a way out of this  I can't let it die I'm not gonna let her  die  my name is Amber chesborough and I am  being held against my will in Venezuela  you want answers she's his wife my  sister we're desperate for something  you better go down there take care of  your sister we don't need money this is  a political stuff don't worry about it  my brother and my husband performing  Special Forces  I know how these decisions are made they  want to prove a raid  we have to get around  I guess we should cancel dinner  how many lives are you willing to trade  for your sister  the CIA wants a war and you're going to  give it to them  the truth is democracy is dead in North  America we we get your influence  rescue they can't find this place  you don't know my family  [Music]  [Music]